[Music]
I'm so I'm Quentin I've been working a
dialogue for the past three years and
I'm leading the data engineering team
and today I'm gonna talk about how we
build highly reliable data pipelines a
dialogue and my hope is that there were
building there will be things that we
didn't learned that can be useful for
you all so I hope that you'll you'll be
able to learn a couple of things out of
this presentation before I dive in a few
words about airlock for those who never
heard of it so we are a monitoring
service for large scale cloud
applications so we collect metrics from
your systems your databases your web
servers but also traces and logs so we
give you a global view of your systems
health and performance and you can set
up alerts on top of these data to know
when something was wrong in your system
so let me come back to the title of this
presentation I said I was going to talk
about reliable data pipelines so the
first question you may have is what does
reliable means so I asked myself this
question and I I came across this
definition that I really like and that I
think is the closest to how we see
reliability at the roadog so basically
it can be defined as the probability
that a system will produce correct
outputs up to some given time T so in
other words you have some time
constraints how can you make sure that
you deliver good data in time as much as
possible so what's interesting here is
that it doesn't mean that you need to
build pipelines that never fail it's
it's not even possible
right so you can spend much time as you
want building your pipelines with the
best coders there will still be failures
but it's okay as long as you can detect
the failures early enough and that you
have ways to fix them you'll be able to
finish before the deadline and your
pipeline will still be reliable in that
sense so that definition in mind I'll be
talking about how we architect our data
pipelines
I will talking about how we monitor the
pipelines to make sure that we detect
those failures early when they happen
and I will talk a bit about what tools
we have in place to cope with these
failures and make sure we can fix the
issues early enough before I dive into
this agenda I wanted to give you an
example of an important product feature
that is powered by one of our big data
pipelines so as I said in the
introduction we collect metrics data so
this is basically time series data a
collection of data points each point is
attached to a metric it has a time stamp
which is when it was sent a value and
list of tags that people can use to
filter their data in the product and we
keep this data at the highest resolution
for at least 15 months in the past and
so people can go back in the past if
they want to they can choose what time
frame they want to see so in this
example they're gonna see the past one
hour in which case we're going to show
one point per second but if they look at
at the past five months for instance
we're not going to show one point per
second because that's just too many
points on the graph and it would be
unreadable like you would have just
spikes like this so we do some
aggregation and we're going to show them
one point per day instead of one point
per second so there are a few ways we
could do this we could load the high
resolution data on the fly and do the
aggregation on the fly but that would be
very slow because we'd have to load
five months of high resolution data we'd
have to do the aggregation so queries
would take minutes so what we do instead
is we have a batch pipeline that I call
the roll-ups pipeline that is going to
pre aggregate all of the metrics data
for all customers and it's going to
produce different aggregations one point
two minutes one point per hour and one
point per day and the query system will
know based on what time frame the user
is looking at it will know what what's
the best resolution it needs to look at
to to fulfill the query so this pilot
this pipeline is running on SPARC it
runs every day in
processes dozens of terabytes of data
and trillion of points and it's one of
our critical pipelines because if it
doesn't run for a day or if it's behind
then there will be gaps on the graphs
and so customer will not be able to see
their historical data so that's why it's
very important that we make sure this
pipeline is highly reliable and I'm
going to use it throughout the
presentation to illustrate my point so
let's start speaking about the
architecture of our pipelines this is a
simplified view of our big data platform
when I speak about data pipelines a data
log you should think Luigi and SPARC
that's that's what we use and I'm
curious like how many people are using
spark in the room
oh yeah that's a that's a lot of people
how many are using Luigi oh so if I
start from the bottom we're using AWS s3
as the persistent storage layer it's
been working really great for us it's
cheap it's highly reliable it has good
integration with all the languages you
can think of so that's where we persist
all of our data on top of this layer we
have the clusters where we run the spark
jobs and we use AWS EMR elastic
MapReduce to provision the clusters
install what we need on on the clusters
and shut them down when they're done and
one thing we do is which is a bit
unusual is we have multiple ephemeral
clusters so that's why I added several
times EMR but I'll come back to that
afterwards and on top of that we built a
custom platform to interact with the
clusters and with the jobs and this
platform as two types of workers as I
said we're using VG for the tasks and
workflow management's and there's the
spark worker which is just in charge of
compiling the code and sending the code
to the right cluster and making sure
that that the job is running and the
users can interact in different ways
with the platform using our web
interface or using the CLI and there's a
scheduler for scheduling recurrent jobs
and we just dated up to
all of these layers I want to focus more
on the clusters layers because we're
doing a few things that are a bit
unusual and that really impacts how we
architect our data pipelines so as I
mentioned what what we do is were using
many clusters so instead of in a lot of
companies you'll still see one giant
Hadoop cluster and people will all round
their jobs on the same cluster and they
will compete for resources we don't do
that what we do instead is that each
pipeline is going to start its own
cluster it's going to run on it and then
when it's done it's going to kill the
cluster so as a result we have dozens of
clusters that are running at a given
point in time this is a snapshot of the
host mapping dialog showing all the
different clusters that we have and each
cluster is very short-lived it has like
a lifetime of about three hours on
average so we do this because it has
several advantages the first one is that
we have total isolation between the jobs
so we know when there's an issue we know
why it's happening like we know what job
is causing the issue whereas if you have
dozens of jobs running on the same
cluster it may be harder to figure out
what job caused the out of memory errors
or a job caused the disk space issues so
isolation is good we can also tailor
each cluster for the need of every job
so if we have a job that is very CPU
bound we're going to use the c3 instance
family in an WS if you're familiar with
it or if the job is using a lot of
memory we're using we're gonna use our
three instances we can also tailor the
size of the clusters for each job and
it's very useful in different situations
like if right behind for instance we can
just push the button double the size of
the cluster and we'll be able to catch
up much faster it's also useful as we
grow we can scale up the size of our
clusters as the data volume increases
and people don't need to wait on loading
clusters so if data scientists or data
analysts wants to run a job analyze some
data it can just
start its own cluster and shut it down
when when he's done he doesn't need to
wait for resources to free up on a giant
cluster and the last advantage is we can
do easier upgrades of EMR Hadoop and
spark
these are usually painful to upgrade
because stuff will break new bugs are
introduced so what we can do here is do
the upgrade on a single cluster first
we're gonna test that everything works
fine we're gonna let it run for a little
while to make sure that it's okay and
once we know that everything is good we
can gradually upgrade all the other
clusters something else that is pretty
unusual is that we are using spot
instances for all of our clusters all
the time so if you're not familiar with
spot instances basically AWS needs to
have a lot of servers sitting around to
be able to serve the capacity of their
users but those servers are not always
being used so what they do is they put
them a discount on the spot market and
you can use these instances at a
ridiculous price so usually we get up to
80 or 80 percent of the on-demand price
but the big downside is that nodes can
die at any time so you're not sure that
you're going to be able to keep your
notes for the length of your job so you
can think of it as having basically cows
monkeys running all the time in our
clusters and killing nodes randomly so
you're probably wondering like how can
we build highly reliable data pipelines
with instances that are killed randomly
all the time it's actually not such a
bad a bad thing because it forces us to
to build our jobs in a way that to make
them falter around and the first
implication is that we cannot have any
long-running jobs because the longer the
job and the more work you're gonna lose
on average and the longer the job the
longer it's going to take for to recover
from a failure so quick a quick
illustration if you have two jobs one is
9 hours by Plan B's cut into three
separate jobs that are persisting
intermediate data so if you have a fail
you have to serve
you're gonna lose seven hours of work
and the job is gonna finish after 16
hours whereas in pipeline be the first
two jobs are done the data is persisted
so you only lose one hour of work and so
you'll be able to finish after 10 hours
so you need to break down your jobs into
smaller survivable pieces and there are
two ways you can bring them down the
first way is vertically so you're going
to identify major transformations in
your jobs and you're going to persist
intermediate data in between
transformations and the second way is
horizonte you're going to partition you
input data and each partition is going
to be processed in its own independent
pipeline so that's what we did for the
roll-ups pipeline that i present it in
introduction so if you remember we're
taking some road time series data as
input and we are producing aggregated
time series data in s3 as the output
using a custom file format that that we
built for optimizing queries so we could
have a single job for that but it would
be huge it would take more than 15 hours
so it's not great for fault tolerance so
there are actually two steps in this
pipeline the first one is the pure
aggregation of the data and the second
one is storing and converting the data
to our custom file format so we broke it
down vertically so now we end up with
two jobs
the first one is persisted they are
greedy edit time series data in packets
in s3 and the second one is doing the
conversion to the custom file format so
ok it's good we have two jobs but it's
still not good enough because as well
scale both jobs will get bigger and
bigger and that there will be too big at
some point so we also partition the
input data the input data is actually
coming from kefka's so it's already
partition following the Kafka
partitioning scheme and on top of that
we created another abstraction that we
call the shards so shard is just a group
of Kafka partitions and each shard is
going to be processed in its own its own
pipeline and so if your shard is getting
too big we're going to be able to split
it very easy
so we end up with like with in this
example eight eight jobs instead of a
single big one which is much better for
four turns so this approach is not free
though it's it's a trade-off between
fault tolerance and performance because
launching multiple jobs has some
overhead that's the first thing and the
second thing is persisting data to s3 is
much slower than keeping the data on
disk in HDFS or keeping the data in
memory so you need to think about the
trade-off between photons and and
performance a few lessons out of it so
we use many clusters for better
isolation and easier monitoring but as a
result we need to break down our jobs
into smaller survivable pieces and
persist intermediate data in s3 and keep
in mind that it's really a trade-off
between performance and for parents so
now I'm going to talk a bit about how we
set up monitoring on these data
pipelines what type of metrics we'll
look at and how we can detect failures
fairly enough so that we can recover
before the deadline when they happen so
as we saw we use many FM l clusters and
all on the on all of the notes in the
clusters we install the data agents
which will collect all like system
metrics logs and traces and send that to
data log now these metrics this data is
only useful if you can look at its
cluster by cluster and so what we do is
we tag the cluster so like by the name
of the jobs usually so you have the
roll-ups cluster where the Rolf's
pipeline is gonna run you have the
anomaly detection cluster where the
anomaly detection job is going to run so
we attach the tag when starting a
cluster in EMR and that the data log
agent is able to pick up that tag and
attach it to all the data that it
collects and sent to daily log and so
that's how we are able to then filter
our data in the log and see the data
cluster by cluster it also gives us a
permanent view of the clusters because
if you have a job that runs every day on
a differ
cluster so the cluster ID will change
the cluster information will change but
the tag will remain the same so we can
look at the metrics over a single month
for instance thanks to the the single
tag that that remains consistent so we
look at different types of metrics the
first types is obviously cluster and
system metrics so we have dashboards
with like all the whole system metrics
that we care about but there are a few
metrics that we care more about because
they cause like common failures in our
jobs the first one is obviously disk
usage so where we have a monitor setup
to get alerted when nodes are running
out of disk so you see that the first
three jobs are totally fine like all the
executors are way below the limits but
the last job some executors are reaching
the limit and the job probably failed on
out of this care so if we get alerted
early enough we can scale up the cluster
and and keep the job running another
thing we look at closely is memory usage
as it's pretty tricky to manage in SPARC
and there's an integration in the data
the data log agents that lets us collect
fine-grain JVM metrics so we can have
like the memory usage by container in
the Spock job so that's what you see on
those graphs and what you see is on the
graph at the bottom some containers are
reaching the limit and then dropping
down so there they're running out of
memory and the job probably probably
fell because of that another thing we
look at closely as I said we use bar
instances so we lose instances all the
time in our clusters and when the spot
market is really unstable all of our
clusters will be basically failing and
jobs won't be able to run so when that
happens we basically need to switch to
andaman notes so well pay more money but
at least we were sure that we're gonna
make progress in our jobs and we know
that it has to happen from time to time
so we have this metric that tells us how
many nodes are killed by EMR and so we
get alerted when this number is too high
the other types of metrics that will get
our work job metrics the system metrics
are good but they don't tell you
anything about what's going on exactly
inside your job so first we look at a
spark metrics that are collected by the
agents and there's one that is specially
useful for us which is the number of
fell tasks in spark spark has a good
mechanism to retry fell task but like
for instance when we're losing too many
spot instances it would keep retrying
and tasks will keep failing and the Java
basically gets stuck and so the only way
to fix this is to stop the job and rerun
it on another cluster so we have an
alert set up on that to know when too
many tasks are are failing in our jobs
we also collect custom metrics inside
the jobs in between major transformation
to know like exactly what's going on
inside the job so this is an example
from the role of spy plane so this is
written in Scala and what you see is
were creating an accumulator that is
going to count how many points are being
processed ending this transformation and
we do that for all major transformations
so that lets us see a graph like this we
know that like if every day we're
processing about 1 billion points but
then the next day were processing only 1
million points like we know there's
something wrong in that stage so we can
identify exactly where the issue happens
we also collect things like how much
time it takes to do some computation so
in this case how much time did it take
to merge two time series together and
that lets us identify potential skews in
the data job metrics and and system
metrics are good for the data engineers
but they don't tell you anything about
the global picture if you remember if
you remember the definition of
reliability that I gave at the beginning
we want the data to be ready before a
certain deadline and so to know if we're
behind or if we're on time we also
monitor data lags so we have an app that
we that will look in as three and that
will report in the
which is basically when was the last
time that the data was updated and then
it's very straightforward to set up
alerts on that so we're gonna set up an
alert like a couple of hours before the
deadline so that we know if the job is
is running behind and we have time to
take some action to to make it faster
like double the size of the cluster for
instance and this is the type of metric
that you can actually show to the
customers of your data because they
don't care about how your job is doing
they just care about when the data is
ready so we provide these these metrics
internally to two people that care about
the data that we produce so if you like
lessons out of this try to measure as
much as possible it's good to have all
the metrics because when there's an
issue you have full visibility on what's
happening in your job so it's very
helpful for debugging set up alerts on
the most meaningful metrics and these
alerts should be actionable so that
people should exactly should know
exactly what they should do to fix the
problem and have some high-level
dashboards with data lags so that in a
single look you know the states of your
different data pipelines so okay we we
know how to detect failures and failures
will definitely happen so you need to
get prepared to to handle failures to be
able to recover as fast as possible and
then finish before the deadline so I'm
going to talk a bit about what tools we
have to recover fast from failures and
how we can limit the customer impact of
our failures so your data data pipelines
will break definitely there are a lot of
things that could happen that could be
hardware failures if especially if
you're using spot instances instances
well fail all the time clusters will
fail if your data volume is increasing
there will be new performance issues in
your job a lot of memory errors these
higher disk needs things like that
you're also depending on some input data
so it could be delayed it could be
corrupted
and finally people are making changes to
your jobs and so they could break stuff
in in the pipelines so to deal with
those values you need to keep two things
in mind you want to recover fast to
finish before the deadline if possible
and if you can't recover fast enough you
need to think about how you're going to
limit the impact of the failure can I
keep my functionalities operational at
the cost of performance and efficiency
and accuracy so to recover fast I talked
a bit already about these points you
cannot have any long running jump
because failures will make it much
longer to recover when there are
spotting stability we have the option of
switching to andaman clusters throw more
money at the clusters and we can always
double the size of the cluster or add
more nodes as we need to if we want to
catch up faster now another thing you
need to think about is how you're going
to rerun your your pipelines this is
your food when your job is running fine
but it produced some bad data or some
incomplete data and then it so you're
going to need to rerun the jobs it's not
always trivial so you need to think
about it ahead of time so it's not
trivial because you need to think about
like where is the data written where do
I need to clean up stuff is the
downstream user already using the data
is it okay if I simply delete it even
though it's already using it so you need
to think about it ahead of time so if I
go back to the roll-ups pipeline it's
one of this pipeline where we're running
jobs is not easy so we had to think
about this ahead of time so if you
remember we're producing aggregated time
series data in this pipeline the
aggregated data is actually written in
one month block so each every day when
the pipeline runs it's going to process
one month of data and writes the updated
data industry in a block of one month we
can't override the data every day
industry because the data is being used
by the live query system and if we
override it there's a an amount of time
when the writes happened
where the data would be corrupted so we
can't directly overwrite it so what we
do instead is we cannot version the data
and so every day the pipeline will will
write to a new location in s3 so as of
with the dates when the pipeline run so
you can think of it as a versioning
system where you have different versions
of your data and then we have this
concept of active location which is just
which is just a pointer to the latest
updated data and so it tells the query
code what's the data that it should use
for each month so if we're on the 22nd
of May the job is gonna run it's going
to write to a new location and what once
it's done it's going to switch the
active location to the new the new
version so what's nice with this system
the first thing it's easy to revert to
previous versions it's just a matter of
changing the active location so if we
realize that data is bad for a 20 second
we just update the active location and
point into the 21st of May and the
second nice thing is that it's easy to
rerun the job it's just a matter of we
basically increment a number appended at
the end of the location and then update
the active location so if you can't
recover fast enough you need to think
about how you're going to limit the
customer-facing impact of of the issue
and the first thing too is to try to
have the late issues to a limited number
of customers and we can do that because
we splits the pipeline horizontally so
since we split the input data in
different charts we know what customer
is in what shard and so when there's an
issue we know what shard is affected
shard see for example so we know that
the other customers are not affected
affected and we can contact the
customers in in shard see for instance
to give them more information about
what's happening and then we also have a
degrading mode for this pipeline meaning
we want to be able to keep the
functionalities operational at the cost
of performance of accuracy so even if
the pipeline is late or if it failed we
want we still want our customers to be
able to query
historical data and so what we can do is
basically tell the query code that okay
a pipeline is late
don't use the aggregated time series yet
instead keep using the high-resolution
data for this period of time so what it
means that customer will still see their
day round on the graphs but it will be a
little bit slower because we're using
high-resolution data and we're doing
more computation on the fly
but at least diversity they will still
see the the data and alerts whilst LCS
will still be operational
another issue we've seen in our pipeline
is that sometimes we have like a very
small number of corrupted files and so
these files would make the whole
pipeline fail
so which doesn't really make sense for
us like we prefer to have most of the
data good for all customers and only
like a few metrics that are affected by
the issue rather than failing the whole
job and affecting affecting all
customers with the issue so we added a
parameter in our jobs that lets us skip
corrupted files and that way we can
basically let the job run and then fix
the issue investigate why there are some
corrupted files and then rerun the job
once we know what the issue is and when
the once the issue is fixed and we can't
do that because we have good monitoring
so we know how many's corrupted files
appeared in the job we know what
customers are impacted whereas if there
are too many corrupted files in the job
you shouldn't ignore those files because
they're probably that's probably a
widespread issue and you need to fix the
issue before running anything so if you
license out of this think about the
potential issues that could happen in
your pipelines ahead of time and get get
ready to handle those failures so I've
tools to recover fast and have tools to
limit the consumer-facing impacts
so I'm getting to to the end of this
list of this talk and I think if you had
four things to learn out of this
presentation it would be these four
points the first thing is know your time
constraints the time you'll need to
invest to make your pipeline reliable
will be highly dependent on how much
time you have to produce the data so if
you have three days to produce some data
obviously you won't spend as much time
as to make the pipe to the data
pipelines reliable as if you have only
two hours to produce the data so know
your constraints the second thing is
break down your jobs into small
survivable pieces a good rule of thumb
for us is to have jobs not bigger than
one or two hours that's that's the
maximum we we we have a monitor as much
as much as possible collect system
metrics job metrics and data lags
to get the global picture and think
about failures ahead of time and get
prepared to handle them to recover fast
and to limit the the customer facing
impacts when you can't recover fast
enough thanks a lot for listening we're
hiring in my team in Paris in New York
and also in a bunch of other teams so if
you're interested to work with us on
large-scale data pipelines come talk to
me come to our booth downstairs or shoot
me an email and I'll be happy to answer
your questions thank you
[Applause]
any question yeah you mentioned about
degrading gracefully when you know the
output of jobs is not correct how do you
know that the job output is not correct
yeah that's a good question
I didn't talk about that but we have
some so in the case of the roll-ups
pipeline we actually produce some dial
tone metrics and then we have an ad hoc
check that runs all the time and that
basically run queries on the dial
metrics and that's how we detect bad
data in this job okay I have one more
question which is you've talked about
spot instances going down have you
considered using like building a cluster
which is hybrid like partly spot
instances and partly on on-demand yeah
we're not doing that right now but
that's something we're going to explore
very soon yeah okay thank you Thanks
hi one of your over this way so it seems
like you're mixing operations and data
engineering are you a DevOps are you
data ops are you really mixing that Ken
above I guess we don't spend most of our
time just maintaining our jobs though
they're they're pretty self
self-sufficient
so I'd say we'd spend like 20 percent of
our time fixing job issues maintaining
clusters stuff like that but we still
spent eighty percent of our time
developing new features developing new
jobs so there isn't a separate operation
to him not for the divider pipelines
this is in the same team
yeah you lunch lots of on-demand
clusters small not maybe not small EMR
clusters and how long it take to launch
it to launch a cluster yeah just a
tablet it's about ten minutes five to
ten minutes okay and do have some small
jobs that don't take like several hours
maybe several minutes you have such
tasks and how you handle it if you have
it we don't have too many small jobs
because usually like the data volume
processes it's pretty big so yeah as
small as small as jobs are like one hour
maybe okay thank you Thanks
hello thank you photo quite interesting
yeah question well about pressing about
the spot instances so you find this too
correctly that your pipelines are
created and when a user does something
in production so it's like kind of like
real-time whether the histories is
looking for then you create a pipeline
to calculate that is that correct so can
you repeat the end yeah if the
pipeline's that you were mentioning they
are related to user activity in
production is that correct
yes so I have a question about pricing
like what is the strategy that you
follow to establish the pricing to say
how much has four instances it's gonna
as gonna value for you how do you start
with the threshold to to say okay now we
go on to on-demand instances and is this
something that Verizon a or every hour
or is that something that you have
figured out and is basically established
price because you know this was gonna
work for you okay so a strategy right
now is just to set our big price for
spare instances to the on demand price
so we're gonna start using instances
when when the demand is higher than that
and we are switching to andaman when
when we're too close to the deadline
basically so when we know that we won't
have time to recover I will switch to on
demand clusters and that happens from
time to time but not every day
definitely
you